screaming skills granted hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to
never again the demo now this is a
horror game about oh don't do that to me
well thank you I got my back turned oh
well I thank you what a favor you're so
kind to me what a power saver really
protector of the environment here okay
well you didn't need to do that I spent
a lot of time putting those blocks in
order there is no greater sorrow than to
recall happiness in times misery geez
we're starting this off with a bang
where's my inhaler where the hell's my
inhaler hello
inhale Oh No
you'd think I would keep that right by
my bed oh is that my inhaler now there
you block do I need to spell out inhaler
can't breathe teddy bear forgive me my
goddamn inhaler but sorry I can't throw
my fur
whoa okay I'm dead apparently I
[Music]
Oh is happening
okay well I'm confused now my dad is
this purgatory hello hi my name is
markiplier and I have no idea what Oh
step into the light that's always a good
sign oh I'm back ah okay take two on
this one let me try to open up like
[Music]
seven one zero five Oh oh god I gotta
keep passing out over and over again I'm
coming
Am I oh okay well I'm sprinting this
time oh it was under my pillow where it
should have been where I should have
looked okay
well that's unfortunate hey bird that I
can't help you I'd rather keep you
trapped nevermind you're gone now
thought you might be wanting to share
some misery with me but apparently not
do I need to do something with these
these gosh darn blocks is that something
that I need to do because I found all of
them I play on the seahorse
ah what a good dad 7:05 this is this is
just weird it's something three six
seven one there's no oh so I'm guessing
507 ten five that's probably it ah not
seven one oh because there is no oh so
it's seven okay oh yes I'm gonna assume
this that's not the prize I wanted be
gone are you doing like that at all
hey there friend up you just want to
turn away from me why won't you look at
me why won't you look at me look at the
tree it's my favorite tree did you know
that's okay you stay there have a good
nap crumpled note more inhale oh oh
pony book oh I'm very organized
okay well things I've got a diary
sometimes when I'm very tired of other
people are just so want to tell
something to my mom
I've read all my thoughts in this diary
he knows everything about me it's like
it's part of me this inhaler I almost
never let it go dad strictly told me
from childhood that if I have it that if
it is far away I could die mom attached
a rope to be worn around the neck well
okay that's good for me then I guess oh
yeah what is that
well I don't like that what a beautiful
day no I love Sundays he don't because I
can luxuriate in my bed until noon what
kind of word is luxuriate for a little
girl for some reason I remember my
dreams very well on Sundays maybe it's
due to the fact that I sleep as much as
I want till the end of dream like
today at a very specific dream usually I
see my mom traveling and meeting new
people like that person but today I saw
Stefan who's that Stefan we played hide
and seek and I hid in the closet in my
room I felt something strange near my
back in the back blue hot air like from
the oven it turned around and I had
failed it in the wall of the closet
behind the closet was a cave entirely of
fire the flame was everywhere I was
scared
suddenly something appeared from the
flame and was ready to come at me that's
anger and I awoke what the hell kind of
story is that you linguistics major
Jesus alright well alright well that's
that's Heiser came back here there's
some kind of game knock knock anybody
back there
shut me down that I regret stepping
through the Wardrobe which whoa whoa the
shamon lie are everywhere please don't
believe your eyes this must be disappear
somewhere it will explode and die and
why are you telling me to run I usually
know that running is bad that means good
oh I don't like this I don't like this
no I don't so now you must be quiet
don't talk with anyone and someone could
be blind it couldn't be dead
you must shun
what are you talking about are you
talking that they can't see me funk funk
get back in the wall back in the world
[Music]
well it's gonna stare that for a bit
is it getting brighter okay well that
was not fun okay I get it all right I
see I see you didn't notice the the meat
hooks
those are nice I'm just gonna go here
and luxuriate better well this squadron
is like one of them oh it's a puzzle how
about you you look through the people
get in the Hall Museum all right what
about this is even in the reflection
beep beep er did you go through the
mirror what do you see what do you see
with your elven eyes I hang you know you
know I want to name you but I really
don't because I don't think that you
should be named I guess it has a certain
charm and that it doesn't have any charm
at all
I'm gonna call you screaming skull
Scranton it screaming Scranton there you
want to grab on to screaming Scranton
there all right fine then whatever
bellowing baby Bristol hey ya know
whoa hey I didn't expect that to work
thank you screaming skull Scranton oh
we're gonna go on an adventure screaming
skull Scranton Oh
oh this is wobbly oh it's extra wobbly
hi bird I remember you from before but
you left me behind
okay I'm looking down oh all right well
this is the wobbly is bridge I've ever
done seen No thank you thank you
did I lose screaming skull Scranton no
where are you screaming skull Scranton
Oh Joe I lost him to the affairs oh what
a tragedy no lilyc yours damn it I lost
screaming skull scrander Wabo Wamba Oh
windy one bow you know what I think I
can forgive myself for that one because
that adventure probably should have
stopped wearily er than it shut up I
made it I'm good
[Music]
I see so this has Mira is broken
[ __ ] oh look at this stupid what a
dumb Laura you know something tells me I
don't want to go there either without
the light because that just doesn't seem
safe
wait there's a shard of glass over there
from the mirror maybe I can get that hey
scram toe you're doing all right over
there good good
hey do the one bow later when I'm not on
you right now okay you understand me yep
do you be okay made it just fine okay
what about you ah I got wait why is
there a hand claw at me from behind this
mirror hang on wait there's there's an
piece of the mirror someone says the
mirror hide a lot of secrets in itself
if you look in the mirror for a long
time you can see your true self and
sometimes it's an indispensable helper
oh that's what the hand is it's my
indispensable helper it's the same man
that turned off the light in my room to
save my parents money on the electricity
bill okay alright you know what you
don't need to do the truffle shuffle
right here I am okay with that you just
let me by Oh let me by let me by like
you don't like you at all how about some
of this one detail you say this detail
I'll fam fixed perfectly all right I
just need to bounce
[Music]
that's that's a look at the look at the
look at the there we go hello oh no I
have a crank don't do that something out
of that okay we're good we're clear
we're good good alright let's put this
in there crank the well I got there some
crank it up if you think I [ __ ] enough
open it oh oh screaming skull sprint how
are you doing here without me
great glad to hear it screaming skull
Scranton you're doing so good in life
hey how are the kids
oh man look like you've been busy with
the family if you know what I mean okay
all right all right well hello can I
help you oh you must be the father Oh
see you've lost weight Oh God Oh miss
mr. Scranton or mr. scream
well I got that oh hello what are you
doing back there aren't you lovely
alright well you know alright
oh I don't like that even a little bit
screaming scoffs granted oh do not tell
me a fairy tale Oh what the hell
oh that was the ender oh okay all right
I guess I'm dead now okay so that is
never again the demo I don't know when
the full version is going to be released
it might be one of those things it's on
Kickstarter I have no idea but it's
really good they got a lot of elements
here that remind me of amnesia the pace
is a bit slower but I kind of like that
about it it lets you build it into it
and gives you this false sense of
security like it reminds me of into the
sleep or into the sleep bed something
does asleep you know the game about the
baby and because it's kind of told from
like a child's perspective so their
innocence kind of like paints the the
terrifying narrative in a very
interesting way and I like it so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you think of this down in
the comments below I'll provide a link
to the demo because maybe maybe there's
a full version coming out soon and you
guys can find out about that too so
thanks again as always in the next video
[Music]